all right let's check out what some of
you had to say about this week of shows
you can always email info
davidpackman.com but Facebook messages
YouTube comments tweets smoke signals
telegrams and snail mail May
occasionally be included the first
message today comes from Facebook I
could give you a hundred of these every
single Friday but it is simply one
you're an imbecile
of course the wrong your
to which our team knows you simply write
back with the correct your y o u
apostrophe re
and then we move on from there we
probably get ah eight to ten of these a
day and probably hundreds via YouTube
comment
uh obviously education a concern in the
United States we're not making fun of
people who lack access to a good
education
what I am pointing to is maybe don't
call other people stupid morons
imbeciles Etc
when you send a three-word message and
one of those three words is just the
wrong word okay so that's my advice it's
not about making fun of people please
let's just uh
let's keep it together folks okay the
bread table
comments about DeSantis and says he's
only a good candidate by comparison to
Trump uh speaking about Biden I mean I
think Dems are in serious trouble if
it's DeSantis versus Biden I don't like
DeSantis personally but I think he's a
very effective right-wing propagandist
and looks better to the average American
voter than two old guys keep in mind the
average voter doesn't have hard set
policy stances and votes largely on
outward appearance social image and
perception listen I don't know if you've
been watching the first two weeks of the
DeSantis president's president
presidential campaign
um he's not an effective propagandist
his appearance and social image or a
disaster he couldn't be less charismatic
he couldn't be more awkward he's doing
the bobble head stuff he used the word
woke seven times in 28 seconds in a clip
that we looked at on Monday if that's a
guy who's relying on his outward
appearance to get elected I think he's
in trouble folks I really do Mr hipster
posted to the David packman show
subreddit ew David why would you go to
Florida for the beaches California is
leagues better Florida is trash
California beaches are infinitely better
and way more ecologically diverse couple
different things I want to mention here
number one
California overall has much more
beautiful beaches from the standpoint of
scenery I'm with you the downsides to
California beaches are that I like to go
in the water and I just don't have it in
me to go in the freezing water of the
Pacific and everybody anytime you say
this to people in California they say oh
no you go you go down to Manhattan Beach
and the waters warm it's warm and then I
step in there and my foot turns blue
I'm too old for this crap guys okay as a
kid I did it I want to be able to just
kind of walk right in this is why I
prefer like Aruba and Mexico but as far
as the United States goes the southern
tip just the very extra tip there of
Florida is a good spot and I have to say
in the summer it's hard to find nicer
beaches on the East Coast than Pensacola
although technically Pensacola was in
the Gulf I understand that but warm even
warmer than over in Miami so listen like
I'm with you about the beauty of it all
in California the whole thing but if I
want to go in the water it's just too
damn cold okay please please
candy hoarding commented Trump 2024 he
pisses off the establishment so that's
the one we need for the people
this is perfect as I've told you many
times before
there is a category of maggots or
magadonians as the new term may be
that doesn't care about policy
doesn't care about ideas doesn't care
about what's good for them or their
neighbors or whatever they care about
quote owning the libs
and so they think if Liberals are mad if
liberals don't like trump it must be
good for the people
it's an incredibly childish and pathetic
way to analyze what we should be doing
in terms of American politics with
elections and thinking about what sort
of policy would be good or bad but this
is what candy hoarding says
Trump because the establishment doesn't
like him most people don't like him I
hate to break it to you but yes but
forty percent of Republicans still like
them and that might be enough to win
Johnny X says it's ridiculous but at the
same time I don't want LGBT characters
in my kids media I know they exist but
that's not something kids should be
exposed to until they are teenagers
think about how stupid this is seriously
seriously you know now as a parent
I start to think about things like okay
when my daughter is three
inevitably she's gonna look around and
see that there are kids who have a mom
and a dad and kids that have two moms
and kids that have two dads and so she's
going to be aware of the fact that there
are these different arrangements and so
in what way would it benefit her or
anybody for me to go out of my way to
make sure that this never comes up like
in school or in media she might see
something on a cartoon that mirrors
reality oh my goodness she shouldn't be
exposed to that and then you're telling
me when she's 13 now I go listen
some kids have two moms
that's a ridiculous way to raise a kid
so I don't really know what this
person's talking about this person may
not even actually have children because
it's very hard to imagine anyway in
which it would be damaging to be aware
of the fact that there are LGBT people
really really wacky stuff and we got a
lot of comments about this the guitar is
love wrote never really understood how
being gay goes against the family unit
you can be gay and still have a family
it happens all the time honestly I don't
think these people actually care about
conservative or Christian values I think
they're just homophobic I agree with
that
I agree with that the family unit is
damaged if there is someone who is gay
gay people are part of families and they
have families it's only damaging if
their family is homophobic and kicks
them out
uh Alberto Garcia is commenting about my
vaccination and says I doubt Pacman took
the Jab
but if he did then I am looking forward
to the day that it works on him so
Humanity does not have to tolerate him
anymore two things number one
um Monday we went very specifically
about the risk of death from vaccines
and we looked specifically at different
vaccines we have data on this stuff I
encourage you if you care about reality
to check it out secondly I doubt Pacman
took the jab there are people in the
audience who think I'm playing a
character on the show it happens all the
time but where people write in I've said
a million times now I've I've told you
what my vaccination situation is with
the covet vaccine
and I've been vaccinated
why on Earth would I lie about that why
who what I don't who would I even be
serving what would be the point I'm not
playing a character on this show I just
tell you the things as they are
place
um RJ Carey about growing Christian
nationalism in the United States and
discussions about transgender identity
and so many different things RJ Carey
says it always cracks me up when people
who do believe that a virgin can give
birth to a supernatural figure lecture
others about biology and what is natural
LOL very much well said RJ very very
much well said
um I you know in general with the
biblical morality types I I would even
go further than this sometimes you know
they'll call me and they'll say David
you know without the Bible without this
without this structure
how do you know what's right and wrong
what's to stop you from just killing
people if you don't have some some
source that says it is wrong to kill or
it is wrong to murder there's a
distinction between kill and murder made
and some religious texts and when I hear
that I I think to myself wait a second
are you saying that were it not for this
supposed sacred text that communicates
to you what in most cases a Jewish
Carpenter in the sky wants you to do
were it not for that and the fear of
Eternal punishment as a result of what
that Jewish Carpenter in this guy wants
you to do or not do you'd be murdering
people like are you saying that without
that you'd be murdering people because
if that's what you're saying it doesn't
make a lot of sense to me I don't need
that to tell me that murder is wrong
anyway it's
I I we don't have to we don't have to
get into it
um here is someone Reminiscing on uh
when people would say the Pledge of
allegiant
I'm pronouncing it that way for a
particular reason Sylvia Potter says I
remember when Republicans would pray and
say the pledge pledge of allegiant
before they started their meeting and we
had a Bible study before school started
and we never had one school shooting
that was never heard of families like
mine would sit around the dinner table
and pray before a bite of food was eaten
we and a lot of other families would get
up every Sunday morning and go to church
watch old news clippings back then and
the news today and tell me if you see
any difference and then tell me God
doesn't exist you are the one with the
big problem I am struggling to follow
this but I guess the argument is when
the Pledge of Allegiance or Allegiance
was set in school and there was Bible
study in school we didn't have school
shootings we also had way fewer guns
that's the first thing I would look at
we had way fewer guns circulating at
that time uh and Beyond before looking
at the Pledge of Allegiance I would
consider the tool that is being used for
the shootings before I look at a Bible I
would consider the tool that is being
used for these shootings but folks that
this is America
folks like that vote and for every
single one of them we need someone who's
going to think critically and rationally
about the issues facing the country and
vote as well to cancel that out
otherwise they will win and that's a
really really scary thing we have a
tremendous bonus show for you today sign
up at joinpakman.com you'll get instant
access and all of the other great member
benefits you're also doing a great thing
to support the work that we do I'll see
you on the bonus show if you're not a
member
then sadly we will not be reunited until
Monday see you then